hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
once again it's time to look at the free
games we'll be getting as PS Plus
subscribers for the month of October
2017 we have a triple a masterpiece a
horror Fright Fest a monster truck or to
a little pool action and two PS Vita
games both of which are available on the
ps4 all of these will be replacing
September's haul on Tuesday October the
3rd with that out of the way let's start
off with the flagship offerings on the
ps4 first up is the critically acclaimed
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain this
is simply jaw-droppingly good playing a
snake after the events of ground zeroes
which we received back in 2015 by the
way you'll be venturing into Soviet
field Afghanistan using snakes elite
tactical espionage skills the new buddy
system allows for a companion to be by
your side such as DD the dog what about
an elite sniper named quiet or a horse
that poops on demand what a time to be a
gamer this one achieved sky-high review
score so let's be honest even if you
played it first time around download it
and enjoy it again next is something
perfectly timed for Halloween amnesia
collection as you'd expect with the
title like that you wake up with no
memory and explore a pants-wetting lee
scary Castle investigating eerie
pathways to try and piece together
Daniels memory if that doesn't fill you
with fear then try another story in
which a wealthy chap named Oswald who
wakes and frantically tries to find his
kids this is a collection of horror
stories so if they don't float your boat
what about playing as justine and
attempting to survive a series of
demented trials sounds lovely doesn't it
the highest review score for this one
came from Game Informer scoring it nine
point two five out of ten I don't know
about you but I won't be playing this
alone just like last month the psvr
title rigs mechanized combat League and
the mobile phone couch quiz that's you
remain on the list so grab them if you
didn't last month even if you don't have
psvr
you never know when Sony will finally
break you down and force you to buy it
so be prepared over to the ps3 and our
first offering is a racing title
shape of Monster Jam battlegrounds this
one is based on the real-life event in
which monster trucks go head-to-head in
a skill-based
2.5 D time trial there's 23 monster
trucks and 45 tracks in which to test
your skills if you've ever played trials
fusion it's in the same vein also on the
ps3 is hustle kings what can I say about
this it's a pool simulator you either
like that type of thing or you don't the
reviews echo that with the high scores
of seven out of ten and then crushing
the low scores of three out of ten it's
the Marmite of the gaming world over to
the under loved Vita and two titles of
both of which can be played on the ps4
first up is hue in this one you'll be
harnessing the power of color to bring
alive a grayscale world playing as hue
you are trying to solve your mother's
disappearance which can only be done
with the help of a rainbow this one has
so much potential and is definitely
worth your time Metacritic has this
warned hovering around 75% the final
title is simply brilliant sky force
anniversary this one has been around for
10 years and is lovingly updated for a
new generation the scroller shooter has
you flying over war zones in a simple
but effective style this is an arcade
classic which is repetitive but
downright addictive IGN gave this one
nine point five out of ten so it isn't
here to make up the numbers this one is
also available on your ps3 so there you
go eight games to get our teeth into
over October 2017 I'm looking forward to
getting back into Metal Gear Solid 5 and
Sky Force anniversary looks too good to
miss I probably would try amnezia but if
I'm honest I'd be a mess afterwards so
I'll avoid that my opinion means
diddly-squat what are you downloading
and what do you think - October's
offerings please let me know your
thoughts in the comments below I'm Adam
from Playstation grenades if you see fit
alike would be appreciated and if you
haven't subscribed already then please
consider us it's been a pleasure I'll
see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]